ادار العالم ظهره لهم فكانوا وحيدين في
وجه الكارثه
كارثه سبقتها مخاطر اهوال واجهها عبد
ورفاقه في الدفاع المدني شمالي سوريا لكن
كارثه الزلزال اليوم انهكتته ورفاقه وفاقت
قدراتهم
الحمد لله استجبنا
للناس المتضرره من الزلزال
التحقنا بمدينه جنديرس لانه كانت ضرر فيا
اكبر من هيك طلبوا مؤازرات على الاغلب من
جميع الدفاع المدني
وكان في ضحايا كتير تحت الانقاض وابنيه
كتير مدمره
والله عيالي ضليت يومين ما اعرف عنه شي
يومين ما اعرف عنه شيء بس انا مامن يعني
انه اهلي بحده
لا احد هنا يترقب خروجنا من تحت الانقاض
انتهت مرحله الصمت وفقد عبد ورفاقه الامل
في العثور على ناجين لكن مهمه انتشار
الضحايا لم تنتهي بعد
يواصلنا العمل تاره بايديهم العاريه وتاره
اخرى بادوات خفيفه
وبما توفر من معدات ثقيله
تمر الساعات وينقضي اليوم ولا اثر للجثث
التي ابتلعها الركام
بعد اربعه ايام من العمل المتواصل يتوزع
فريق الدفاع المدني بعضهم يتابع العمل
واخرون يذهبون لاخذ قسط من الراحه
[موسيقى]
ان كانوا في دوامه المخاطر فهم عرضه لها
مرحبا بابا
في هذه السياره تقضي عائلته يوميات النزوح
بعد ان تصدع منزلهم والشهوده
الله ربي يسلمك ويرضى عليك يا ابي هنا
ينام اطفاله لكنهم اليوم ظلوا حتى ساعه
متاخره من الليل يرقبون عوده والدهم يعلم
الاب انها لن تكون الا ساعه قليله سيبقى
الاطفال بعدها وحدهم في السياره ويبقى
الاب ورفاقه وحدهم في مواجهه الكارثه عمرو
حلب الجزيره ريفو